bonjour et bienvenue en direct de halle
est à cala l'un des magnifiques volcan
de hawaï en particulier sur l'île de
maui et c'est un cadre assez idéal faire
un titre il est vraiment fou fou fou ces
décors c'est vraiment le décor idéal
pour vous parler des défilés de
moneyweek nous préférer voilages et on
va faire un défilé sion mon énigmes
préféré qui est à l'énigme aider les
enfants donc un père a deux enfants
l'un d'eux est un garçon qu'elle est
apprêté que l'autre un garçon aussi
basse et ça c'est vraiment une énigme
aurait charrié parce qu'elle mêle
énormément de choses ça peut paraître
être un point de match on fait ça c'est
plus utile que ça c'est vraiment un
problème qui vivent à au coeur de ce que
c'est que de connaître et de comprendre
de savoir et ça va même au coeur d'or en
fait la philosophie du savoir dont vous
savez que je suis leur incroyable
aficionado à savoir le boys and his mme
bien comprendre cette énigme c'est bien
comprendre le mécanisme et c'est
extrêmement difficile moi et m'a fallu
des années littéralement en fait
vraiment j'ai compris brugvin j'ai
trouvé une réponse satisfaisante à cette
énigme une fois après seulement que mon
arme ou livre a été publié c'est un
petit peu gênant de bien mais il ya
énormément de propositions de réponse à
cette énigme qui sont pas satisfaisantes
et renaissance et du coup avance il
avait une idée en tête probablement elle
sera pas directement satisfaisante et je
vous invite à longuement y réfléchir à
bien y penser à penser à toutes les
subtilités qu'il peut y avoir
mais surtout elle a cherché à avoir une
réponse pleinement satisfaisante
et puis pensez à l'éclair bien sûr donc
comme toujours dans les commentaires
voilà donc j'espère vous revoir bientôt
dans quelques semaines on va disséquer
un peu tout ça et puis on va parler
longuement de benjani sme également de
comment mieux débattre
ciao